the European Union's currency the euro
has been legal tender for 40 years over
18 billion euro banknotes are in
circulation today if there are all piled
up together this would take you to the
moon and back three times and 115
billion euro coins in circulation are as
heavy as a thousand high speed trades
the total value of both notes and coins
in circulation is over one trillion
euros the European Union is working to
protect euro banknotes and coins firstly
by defining their security features to
prevent the euro from being
counterfeited a close look at the coins
reveals that there are slightly magnetic
have different edges and different size
weight thickness and color still around
a hundred and fifty thousand counterfeit
coins a year are detected in circulation
unfortunately some before they find
their way into people's purses the most
counterfeited coin is the two euro coin
the European Commission also enforces
action against counterfeiting by taking
part in seizures providing expertise to
national authorities and analyzing
falsified coins the European Central
Bank does the same for banknotes about
900,000 falsified notes are removed from
circulation per year this is one note
out of 20,000 in total between 30 and 40
million euros worth of fake banknotes
are seized every year the most
counterfeited notes are the 20 and 50
euro bills
that's why security features in the
newest banknotes were enhanced to make
counterfeiting more difficult
they include watermarks micro print and
infrared and ultraviolet properties the
new 20 euro note also has a portrait
window in the hologram showing Europa
when held against the light
as organized crime operates globally the
European Commission also organizes
programs to Train policemen
government officials and bankers in
counterfeiting prevention both in the
euro area and internationally finally
the European Commission cooperates with
all actors involved in euro protection
the European Central Bank Europol and
Interpol and national authorities
prevention enforcement training and
cooperation four ways the EU protects
your money the European economy stronger
together